ihr könnt ja mal in die kommentare
schreiben was ihr zu meiner veränderung
sagt früher und heute erkennt man dass
ich mal ich war oder dass ich etwas
glaubt und jetzt willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich hab natürlich geht's
gut wurde ich nicht ich habe genau
gerade so ein kindergeburtstag hier im
innenhof deswegen entschuldigt würde die
hintergrundgeräusche der kinder
vielleicht hört man es auch gar nicht
weiß nicht genau
allerdings ist es wieder typisch ich
will wieder machen und irgendwas ist
wieder los apropos kinder
das ist ja nun wirklich sehr schöner
übergang hier ich habe mir nämlich leute
was echt interessant ist überlegt das
gab es auf youtube auch wirklich noch
nie
ich habe ja damals angefangen mit den
videos ich erwarte euer alter dann kam
ich reagiere auf eure zeugnisse und
irgendwie wollte ich jetzt noch mal was
neues machen und vorgestern im video
habe ich aus meiner abiturzeit und
vorgelesen und da war hat auch ein
kinderfoto von mir drin und ich bin
jetzt auf die idee kommen dass ihr mir
einfach mal auf instagram also ich hab
euch auf instagram gebeten wenn ihr das
nicht folgt wollten wir auf jeden fall
jetzt schnell schickt mir bitte ein
aktuelles foto von euch und ein foto was
ein bisschen her ist und dann haben wir
also zwei unterschiedliche fotos und man
kann halt die veränderung sehen und nein
wenn jetzt im titel gelesen habe ich
reagiere auf euer aussehen früher was
ist heute ich will hier nicht aussehen
bewerten oder sowas so was habe ich auf
youtube auch schon gesehen das finde ich
absolut oberfläche und scheiße es geht
einfach nur um die veränderung von
früher war's das jetzt wie man sich halt
verändert weil ich finde das ist
manchmal echt extrem kreis hier zum
beispiel war ein foto von mir was
ungefähr keine ahnung 15 jahre alt ist
wenn nicht sogar noch länger und hier
könnt ihr mich sinn so sehe ich gerade
auch die ähnlichkeit ist auf jeden fall
da vor allem von den augen sagen viele
aber aber ich bin auf jeden fall sehr
zufrieden wie ich heute aussehen
manchmal weniger manchmal mehr ja ich
habe eine menge fotos bekommen ich würde
sagen belabern gar nicht lange auch wenn
ich wahrscheinlich schon wieder übels
langel aber wenn ihr bock aber auch nach
dem patt bei 10.000 likes machen wir
dass dallas noch nach oben da hab ich
das geklingelt sohn wir fangen an mit
der marie glaub ich werd ich mir ein
foto von früher geschickt ich kann
natürlich nie genau sagen wie lange ist
das her
ich kenne euch jetzt ja nicht sieht ein
bisschen wirklich aus aber jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt ja und hier haben wir marie
heute mit snapshot filter das gab es ja
früher noch nicht keine ahnung wie viele
jahre ist dazwischen liegen also wie als
sie heute ist weiß ich nicht das musst
du dir ja auch gar nichts dazu schreiben
aber wirklich sehr hübsch
und ich muss sagen wenn ich mir zum
beispiel das noch mal angucken und dann
das so wirklich ähnlichkeiten oder das
aus diesen mal das wurde das ist schon
schwer
also ich glaube so gerade mit 11 12 13
14 jahren verändert man sicher noch mal
ziemlich stark vielleicht sind die augen
ein bisschen gleich hier keine ahnung
aber coole veränderungen wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten foto und das ist
die lisa früher hier weiß ich auch nicht
wie alt sie da war ich will immer so
schätzen im nahen um 6 6 oder 7 und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie sie heute
aussieht 123 auch mit snapshot filter
warum macht ihr alle so ein snapshot
schilter drauf er leute mich für echt
mal interessieren ob sie in keine ahnung
20 jahren wenn man sich dann kinder
fotos angucken ob die ganzen kinder dann
viele kinder fotos haben mit
irgendwelchen filtern weil sie halt
damals mit irgendwie snapshot filter
instagram filter fotografiert wurden
also wenn man das mal überlegt weil das
könnte ja echt seien willkommen in
unserer welt ja hallo wer kommt denn
jetzt entschuldigung für die störung auf
jeden fall ist das glaube ich lisa und
lisa sieht heute so aus ich würde sagen
gut lisa ist jetzt wahrscheinlich noch
nicht so alt 14 15
aber hier ist es jetzt so da sag ich mal
bis auf die haarfarbe erkennt man das
schon übels krass vor allem von den
augen her und der nase und den mund und
das war's aber es ist ja irgendwie so
bei manchen kann man das wirklich sofort
erkennen und manche sehen ganz anders
aus ihr könnt ja in die kommentare
schreiben was er zu meiner veränderung
sagt früher und heute erkennt man dass
ich mal ich war oder dass ich erkennt
man das wenn man sich das foto anschaut
dass das mal ich war und heute so
aussehe oder er nicht schreibt in die
kommentare
und wir kommen jetzt zu einer meiner
ältesten zuschauerin glaube ich und zwar
hat mir die claudia über instagram ein
foto geschickt und claudia meinte sie
ist schon so 50 und die haben wir
claudia einmal als kleines kind da gab
es nicht mal da gab es nicht mal
farbfotografie und claudia das ist
claudia das geht also ich finde es ja
echt cool dass du köln fern bist weil
hier ist ja auch das kölner stadion
sofort um die ecke oder vielleicht bist
doch gar keinen köln verein keine ahnung
ja das war wirklich witzig ist komplett
haben 14 17 keine ahnung irgendwie so
die meisten sind halt etwas jünger und
dann kam claudia ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen das freut mich immer sehr wenn man
auch irgendwie manchmal so mehr
nachricht bekommen von älteren leuten
weil man das ja eigentlich gar nicht so
wirklich denkt dass auch ältere leute
die videos schauen aber danke für das
foto und hier kann ich jetzt auch keine
wo ja das ist ja echt ein langer weg der
veränderung aber wenn man sich jetzt das
wollte nochmal anschaut und dann das
polare übrigens das wollte ich noch
sagen ich habe mir auch überlegt das
sind jetzt zwar keine trends aber zum
sommer hin nochmals einen zweiten anlauf
zu starten was dreadlocks angeht jemand
kurzer ausschnitt
hey leute ich weiß ich schwimme
also ich war mit dem kopf unter wasser
und die waren sofort weg ihr könnt ja
gern mal in die kommentare schreiben was
ihr davon haltet und wir machen weiter
mit der alisha oder so ich weiß es nicht
war ganz genau ich habe die namen alle
nicht aufgeschrieben auf jeden fall
haben wir alle schon einmal als kind und
einmal jetzt also wenn man sich einmal
das foto anguckt und dann wieder auch
dass ihr switched man erkennt schon die
ähnlichkeit und ich muss wirklich sagen
das ist ein echter hübsches foto ist
immer schwer dann die passenden worte zu
finden aber das foto gefällt mir
schöne grüße elisa ja man erkennt auf
jeden fall die ähnlichkeit zwischen
früher und heute wenn ich mir jetzt mal
das foto anschauen also dass ältere
sieht man ja sie ist schon ein bisschen
geschminkt es geht echt gut aus und wenn
man sich dann das foto von früher
anschaut könnte das sein dass die lippen
auch geschminkt sind oder halt mit
lippenstift gemacht keine ahnung sieht
irgendwie so ein bisschen so aus so
kommen wir zur nächsten zuschauerin
irgendwie habe ich hier nur weibliche es
tut mir leid die männer haben nichts
geschickt das war nicht auch sehr cool
und zwar wurden wir hier so eine ganze
transformation geschickt sie hat auch so
body transformation fotos mit bei
gehängt aber die nehme ich jetzt mal
nicht mit rein und zwar hier einmal das
foto von vor keine ahnung fünf jahren
oder so es handelt sich übrigens um die
rechte person glaube ich genau also hier
sieht man ja auch so vom stil her dass
das schon ein bisschen älter sein müsste
und jetzt ist aktuelle foto und hier
muss ich auch sagen sie hat sich auf
jeden fall echt gut gemacht ist
richtig hübsche frau geworden ich habe
jetzt keine ahnung vielleicht bis zu 16
oder 17
aber ich würde schätzen dass du so 20
bist ja ich bin das erste mal
interessant zu sehen wie sich menschen
so verändern deswegen sage ich auch
immer gerne ich kriege ja auch öfter mal
nachrichten jo alex mein aussehen das
voll blöd was soll ich machen und so
leute erstmal ganz wichtig ich finde man
sollte nie über sein aussehen meckern
ist halb so wie man ist und da gibt es
gar keinen grund nicht zufrieden mit zu
sein trotzdem kann ich sagen dass wenn
jetzt irgendwie nicht mit euch zufrieden
seid oder so wenn euch eure haare nicht
gefallen das teil nicht gefällt die nase
nicht gefällt und so weiter dafür gibt
es doch bestimmt eine menge andere
sachen die ihr euch gefallen an euch
selber und wenn das nicht so ist dann
kann man natürlich auch über die jahre
sich nochmal komplett verändern vom
style er von den haar her und so weiter
deswegen seit bitte immer zufrieden mit
euch selber weil es keinen grund dafür
gibt es nicht zu sein finde ich jetzt
bin ich mal wieder viel zu weit vom
thema abgedriftet die haben wir noch ein
foto von antonia glaube ich früher
irgendwie hast du das komische sachen im
gesicht na ja und heute also man erkennt
auf jeden fall die ähnlichkeit irgendwie
merkt gar nicht dazu ja auch gar nicht
sagen ich versuche mal noch ein bisschen
das ganze auszuformulieren aber mir
fällt nichts ein
ja das war jetzt einfach mal ein paar
kinder fotos von euch und aktuelle fotos
von euch die mir geschickt habe ich
finde das echt interessant deswegen
können wir noch viele weitere übernahmen
zu schicken für noch eine folge lasse
noch nach oben da wir das gerne hätte
ansonsten ganz wichtig instagram und
snapshot ab und das kasse ist es ist
einfach gestern dieses paket angekommen
so glaube ich ein handy drin ist was ich
jetzt zwei mal haben also ich habe zwei
handys bekommen obwohl ich nur eins
bestellt habe das wirke sich auch die
videos dazu könnte ich auch noch mal ein
paar machen bzw
dieses handy verlosen deswegen sehen wir
uns auf jeden fall morgen wieder auf
drei tore